this is the meeting Ultra sent to us and
sponsored by kendao it's a first of its
kind all-in-one conferencing solution
for small large or any size meetings and
when I say all in one I mean it because
it's a complete plug-and-play solution
with one power cable requiring nothing
else to work since it comes packed with
two 15.6 inch touchscreen displays dual
4K HDR cameras giving you a full 360
degree view of the room and finally a
full-fledged Android 12 operating system
built in now before I get into all the
details like how it works all the specs
and all the features I want you to
imagine a scenario like something from
the show succession where this product
fits perfectly you've got the entire
board sitting around a table and Kendall
calling in on his cell phone not being
able to see anything that's happening in
the room now imagine the condau meeting
Ultra right there in the middle of the
table using AI to capture and frame each
person in the room as if they had their
own laptop and webcam connected with
eight beamforming microphones capturing
everyone's voice with a bunch of
different modes for putting them up on
the screen that's just a hint of what
this thing can do so let's jump into
some more details Kendall actually has
some previous models that work very well
featuring a similar 360 degree camera
setup and built-in speakers but they
require an external TV or monitor for
them to work the ultra fixes that
problem and makes it a true all-in-one
setup with the Dual built-in full HD
displays which is what helped it win a
CES 2023 Innovation award but what makes
it even more special is that there are a
bunch of ports built into the base like
two USBC ports one for power and another
to connect a computer for sharing both
audio and video which is a must for
showing off presentation patients but
what's really unique is that it comes
with an rj24 ethernet port for not only
reliable internet but it also supports
power over ethernet meaning you don't
need to actually plug it into the wall
for power so you can easily mount it up
or hang it from the ceiling upside down
using the quarter inch screw hole on the
bottom with software support to flip the
display and Camera orientation upside
down it also supports Wi-Fi 6 for
connectivity and it can connect to any
5G hotspot so you can get connected no
matter where you're at it's got three
USB a ports for connecting peripherals
like a mouse and keyboard to control the
OS if you'd prefer not to use the touch
screen or let's say you have a huge
table for your meeting and it also comes
with Bluetooth 5.0 as well for
connecting accessories that way and even
better it actually comes with its own
remote control for situations where you
can't reach the displays so all all of
the bases are covered it also comes with
three HDMI ports two of which are HDMI
2.1 so you can output to two external
displays and an HDMI 2.0 port for screen
sharing from a computer but even better
it supports over the air screen
mirroring so you can use Miracast and
Apple's airdrop to share screens from
IOS Mac OS Android and Windows based
devices it's also got a Kensington lock
and a Micro SD card slot that supports
up to one terabyte of data for taking
photos and video clips and then finally
there's a convenient lens cover for
privacy that covers both of the cameras
the touchscreen displays themselves are
very responsive with IPS panels and 10
point capacitive touch so anyone on
either side can control it and each
display is on a hinge for adjusting the
angle and as far as app support there's
a huge selection of aptitude from
including the most popular ones like
Zoom Skype slack Google meets and more
which you download directly onto the
meeting Ultra itself now the really cool
part is that it uses a combination of
their AI algorithm 4.0 and a powerful
eight core CPU for core GPU and six tops
npu to detect each person in the room
and automatically frame them into the
meeting it also uses AI to detect who is
speaking and put them up on the UI as
the speaker similar to how Zoom or other
conferencing apps work except that the
meeting Ultra will automatically track
the speaker with very low latency even
as they're moving around to give a
presentation the eight microphones on
the top work together alongside an AI
noise reduction algorithm to reduce
ambient noise in the room and improve
the mic quality which has a 5.5 meter
radius voice pickup range so anyone on
the other end of the meeting will be
heard heard clearly from the 10 watt
Hi-Fi speaker now as far as the camera
quality it's actually very impressive
for a fish eye lens since it features 4K
30fps HDR video with a built-in noise
reduction algorithm but even better
there are a bunch of presentation modes
to choose from including multi-attendi
framing main speaker focusing and all
attendee mode which will show the entire
fisheye lens for both sides so you can
see everyone at once and to add to all
of that it's got a bunch of security
features for your privacy like a
one-step log out a lockdown API a
Bluetooth toggle and it won't store your
IP address or location so all of this
coming together in one package basically
makes it the perfect solution for
meetings of all sizes compared to having
everyone in the room log into their own
device and risk connection issues the
condau meeting Ultra covers everyone all
at once and all it takes is a single
cable now as far as my own experience
with it I'm obviously just a YouTuber
and I don't have a large amount of board
members that have meetings all the time
so I can't take full advantage of this
thing but so far I'm really impressed by
the 4k camera quality and the face smart
tracking which works very well I'm also
pleasantly surprised by how Snappy the
whole system and UI works with apps
opening up quickly and having no lag or
reliability issues while going through
the system and settings which shows that
this thing is properly matched up in
terms of Chip performance it's also cool
that it has a home bar on the bottom
which lets you swipe up to switch
between apps and it works very very well
even supporting split screen with two
apps open at the same time which I
wasn't expecting at all another cool
feature with the camera is that in
speaker mode it can automatically add
more people in frames as they come into
the room which actually works really
well well and then on the top of the
meeting ultra bass we have physical
button controls like the power button a
mode button that toggles between
different modes very quickly volume
buttons for the speaker and a mute
button as well the touch input also
worked very well being quick and
responsive detecting every touch and
gesture that I made without issue
especially since the displays are on a
hinge so you can adjust your viewing
angles so with all of that said I've got
to give props to Condado for creating
such an Innovative all-in-one device
that makes it incredibly easy for
businesses and groups to conference
together without having to pay someone
to set up a computer webcams and
whatever else it's just one simple
device that does it all with a single
cable and reliable Android 12 software
and can dial meeting Ultra standard is
released at the same time as a
screenless and even more cost effective
version so if you're interested in
checking one of these out I'll have a
link Down Below in the description and
pin com comment to where you can order
one for yourself so let me know if you
have any questions or comments down
below and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
foreign